man that's got a man who is successful  right a man who is a multi-millionaire  had to go through Blood Sweat and Tears  and hard work consistently to become a  millionaire you can be 22 and pretty and  and a Instagram model and that man can  go into your DMs and say look and I'm in  Dubai and I've got a yacht right I'll  fly you over and that he can have 12  women on his yacht yeah right who are  dancing and having a great time and  those women are literally on on benefits  in the UK right but Batman has had to  Toil and work and Blood Sweat and Tears  and women that's what they're trying to  say women you you don't understand you  live life on Easy Street you know you  don't understand you live like men if  you find a successful man trust me that  man has had to go through the hell to  become successful you can you can  actually be next to a successful man and  not have done much